the Joe Rogan experience now kickboxing
is huge in Europe it means yes very big
people with big people I mean I had Rico
Verhoeven on and we discussed this like
how enormous kickboxing is in Holland
and in Europe
yeah and in America for whatever reason
it never caught on
I thought I don't understand it I've
been a fan of glory and I've been trying
to tell people about them for a long
time I cannot blame and you would say
for that good the the legalized MMA so
MMA just more more attractive for people
you know the people who doesn't know
[ __ ] about about fighting they just
watch MMA is like Oh two people are
fighting that's interesting you know
keep boxing and like things like sport
like wait I kick boxing if you doesn't
know the rules
scandal yay you just watch and you don't
you don't understand you don't
understand but MMA is more easy to
understand you know yes just yeah just
yeah yeah two people so I don't I really
don't know why keep boxing it's not easy
it's not maybe at the same level as Emma
Maine USA
well what's crazy to me is boxing is
very respected in the United States and
MMA is very respected but one of the
things that people like about MMA is
stand up
they're like the striking yeah but the
best striking is like glory yeah or Muay
Thai like the best elite kick boxers are
the best strikers that's right but I
think people love the cage
people love the blood so small gloves no
that's why that's what people like
people don't like you two don't like how
you say that knockdown like ko
or nothing yeah they don't like the brag
and one two three no they like they like
to see to watch ko so that's what I
think I would prefer yeah I mean they
well is there a movement at all to try
to get mm a full MMA legalized in France
I think in January is gonna be is gonna
be okay so they're gonna have to allow
strikes on the ground yeah
everything in resume soon on January
hello in general and I think you were
saying in the coming so they're probably
yours he in Paris yeah for sure
okay that sounds wild yeah yeah well the
more guys like you get involved in MMA
though the more it complicates
kickboxing though because like when
elite fighters world champions like
yourself make a jump to MMA then people
might look at kickboxing as a stepping
stone instead of as a valid individual
sport yeah yeah that's right but you
mean when a guy a step from kickboxing
to MMA yeah they're like maybe people
won't care as much about kickboxing
because they'll look at it as a stepping
stone to MMA yeah yeah of course
and yeah yeah that's right that's what I
that's what I wanted I want to do also
because I think for a guy from
kickboxing to to go in MMA it's not
really difficult for him if yeah if you
learn the ground game and brushing
technique then defense if you learn that
it's gonna be yeah more simple than a
guy who come from wait I you know Maya
is is really different like kickboxing
kickboxing when you fight them
kickboxing you moves a lot already you
know this thing standing target instead
of Muay Thai we tell you that if you
watch Metta a fight they don't move a
lot you know the still and the fight is
is all about powers for kicks or punches
so why do you think that's different
because the clench because the elbows
knees like because of the the the
movement the movement in MMA they stay
still and in key boxing the there is no
you know there is no break you know they
just keep fighting we're at 3 1 2 3 1 2
3 and then in Muay Thai is more like 1 1
1 elbow knees and yeah also but the
clean is good for everything because
then you know in the Thai class yeah
this is good for me
now in France is it easy to get
wrestling do you do you get wrestling
training I in France I get grappling
training
I think here in USA you call that BG
noogie noogie yeah that's why that's why
I'm training in France
what about takedowns or takedown defense
wrestling but you know this this style
of of noogie training I get is a it's a
little bit different like as BG because
we start on our feet uh-huh and and we
use the whisk and then after the
takedown we continue right so it's not
like an an Olympic West ring right but
is they call that luta livre
I don't know Lucha Libre is what they
call Brazil but I know you're saying
yeah yeah yeah so in America most
presume jujitsu they start on the ground
are ready to start on the knees or
something like that to avoid accidents
because you know you got a class full of
40 people rolling around together and
they're trying to tackle each other and
yeah yeah people blow their knees out
and things like you know that's why I'm
training in the in Paris very big team
the coaches mediate man is very good and
he say for the photo shoot I'm very very
good Island fast island reef and course
you ready - yeah